good afternoon I am pleased to tell you
that the Commission has just adopted our
proposal for the first ever European
climate law this proposal sets in stone
our objective to be climate neutral in
2050 and 2050 is no longer impossible
distant to imagine and my children will
be a bit younger than I am now when we
have 2050 so as I have a glimpse of the
possible environment they will likely
experience well this glimpse is pretty
sobering if we don't act now and the
science is very clear
climate is part of the natural work
world that sustains us and this natural
world is severely endangered it is high
time to act and this climate law is part
of the European contribution to this
action it will be our compass for the
next 30 years and it will guide us every
step on the way as we build a
sustainable new growth model before we
adopted the climate law this morning I
was very pleased to invite a special
guest to address the College of
Commissioners I'm referring to late
attuned back she will also be younger
than many of us here in the room when we
reach 2050 and greater speaks for many
of her generation when she calls for
more action to tackle climate change
climate change is caused by us so in
other words it's up to us to make a
turnaround and the European climate law
puts in legislation our target to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by net zero to
net zero by 2050 it gives us the tools
to measure the progress against this
long term goal it gives us the
possibility to take corrective measures
if this is necessary if we fall behind
our own
and we will draw the path from 2030
every step to 2050 that is necessary
this path 2030 to 2050 will be done as
soon as we've finished a very detailed
impact assessment work that is something
which is necessary we have promised to
Council we have promised it through the
European Parliament and I think it's
very important to convince everybody to
go down this path with us the text of
the climate law if you look at it is
actually a rather short and it is rather
simple but what it commits to us is of
the utmost importance the climate law
will oblige the European Union to take
our climate goals into account in all
future policies and legislation it is a
binding legal obligation it offers
predictability
it offers transparency to for example
the European industry to investors to
public authorities and this is what they
are calling for this is what they asked
us to do because it gives them certainty
about what needs to be achieved and it
gives them certainty at what pace I see
the climate transition as a huge
opportunity for Europe to get the first
mover advantage I know what European
businesses are capable of I know by
experience that we are continent of
innovators and of pioneers and
entrepreneurs and this climate law will
set in stone
Europe's position as a climate leader on
the global stage and I'm always still
convinced that the climate law will
inspire many of our partners to raise
their own ambitions as we move towards
cup 26 in Glasgow later this year
however if some do slip behind with
their Paris agreement goals we are also
ready to protect our European industry
from the risk of carbon leakage
and that is why we have launched today
work including a public consultation on
a carbon border adjustment mechanism it
will make sure that there is for our
European industry a level playing field
this is necessary for them to engage in
this transition we will of course design
this mechanism with stakeholders in
Europe and Beyond in a very inclusive
and very transparent manner Europeans
want to live on a continent that masters
its own destiny and takes control of its
own future well I think climate
neutrality is European destiny and I
think competitive and sustainable
economy is the best we can get for a
European future the European climate law
is part of this ambition thank you very
much for your attention vice president
timmermans